faire loisirs gustatif avec à cassis une
innovation pour touristes futé la piste
des vins sorte de safari bouteilles dont
gérard paolini est sorti indemne
cassis est connu pour le soleil son site
maritime le cap canaille et son vin mais
excepté le littoral peu de gens ont
visité les 160 hectares de vignes et
circuler en tout terrain sur les hautes
collines où poussent le pin d'alep le
chêne kermès la bouillir le romarin et
bien sûr la ligne
la plupart de ces pistes traverse des
domaines privés et inspiré par l'office
de tourisme l'appel de ses collines les
randonnées en 4 4 et les dix bouteilles
de cassis les touristes sont de plus en
plus nombreux à faire du safari photo et
du tastevin sur les hauteurs de cassis
vingt deux premiers qui est peut-être un
peu plus alcoolisée que l'autre qui est
beaucoup plus parfumé à vous parce que
c'est ce qu'on va goûter en premier les
associés de cassis ont fêté cette année
leur cinquantenaire la production
limitée au seul vigneron ne connaît pas
la mévente
la première mention certaine de ce
vignoble remonte à 11 199 une vieille
histoire donc
alors que vous avez encore des cuves en
bois de la réception du vin rouge abbès
pour l'appellation cassis surtout
renommé pour le vin blanc
certains viticulteurs on continue à
faire du vin rouge
personnellement je n'avais pas le volume
nécessaire pour la commercialisation
alors j'ai arrêté le vin rouge fait
surtout du blanc et très peu de rose et
nous sommes deux viticulteurs les
cépages de blancs sans la marsanne lui
ni blanc la clairette le boulet le
sauvignon et pour les rouges et rosés
nous avons le grenache carignan le
mauvais goût et le cinsault il faut au
moins une trois cépages pour avoir la
création dans la qualité du vin que nous
voulons faire nous foulons le plus
rapidement 2000 kg de raisin que
contient ce pressoir l'après c'est dur à
peu près une heure et quart on essaie de
faire plus rapidement possible le jus de
raisin est envoyé dans des cuves de
débourrage on nous laisse en 24 à 48
heures et nous prendrons que le clair
que nous allons envoyer dans notre cuves
de fermentation qui se trouve dans la
carte dans le roi sous terrain après